sinan ist autohändler und sein autohaus
in bad neuenahr-ahrweiler wurde von den
fluten fast komplett zerstört wir können
gleich auf die bilder dazu sehen sie
dann erstmal vielen dank für deine zeit
vor einem autohaus ist nicht mehr viel
übrig du stehst mittlerweile jetzt vor
dem nichts was machen die bilder mit dir
wenn du dahin blickst wie geht es dir ja
es geht mir sehr schlecht also man hat
das was man es über jahre aufgebaut hat
wenn er vom paar stunden verloren ich
selbst war ja im urlaub bin aus dem
flieger gestiegen und am nächsten morgen
habe ich dann meine existenz im matsch
und schlamm gesehen also ich glaube
jeder kann sich vorstellen wie ich
persönlich im schüler aber das ist nicht
nur ich es sind doch die anwohner sind
die anderen geschäfte die nachbar
gewesen alle am boden und wie es
weitergeht wissen wir zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt nicht wie hoch ist der schaden
bei dir und sind schon einige von den
sofort helfen bei dir angekommen also
sehr schaden beläuft sich bei mir jetzt
die gebäudeschäden ausgenommen auf circa
100.000 euro wir hatten draußen vier
fahrzeuge stehen in der halle stand ein
fahrzeug was auch schon auch die
ausblick darum gewartet hat also der
schaden des fundaments das hat man es
scheint über jahre aufgebaut und wie
gesagt dass innerhalb von branche und
alles zerstört worden
von den soforthilfen müssen noch gar
nichts angekommen also keinen widerstand
jetzt wird für die privaten haushalte
das was ja auch eben gezeigt habe diese
1100 euro in aussicht gestellt
für die geschäfte gibt es erstmal gar
nichts ich habe auch heute noch mal
morgens bei der ihk angerufen die hat
mich dann an die kreisverwaltung weiter
geleitet dann habe ich bei der
kreisverwaltung angerufen und die sagten
zu mir
sie wissen aber nicht wo die geschäfte
jetzt diese 5000 euro die in aussicht
gestellt wurden
wo man die beantragen kann als geschäft
also wirklich wissen tut das niemand
und was auch sehr ärgerlich ist dass ich
letzte woche sonntag war ich auch schon
mal hier live dazu der erhalt na ja
gesagt
es werden auf jeden fall 10.000 euro
fließen
die wollen jetzt einfach mal wird dort
5000 euro und wie man über antrag tweedy
ausgezahlt werden waren die ausgezahlt
werden kann uns niemand sagen
und wir stehen als einer woche im
schlamm versuchen alles aufzuräumen
aber wo die ganzen spendengelder langen
und wann das alles ausgezahlt wird weiß
niemand wann wir uns weder ich noch die
nachbarn noch die freunde noch die
anderen geschäfte sind einlagen von mir
persönlich kommen sie hier nach berlin
zu bild wir haben ganz gute kontakte in
die politik
wenn der minister altmaier das so gesagt
hat dann lade ich sie herzlich ein zu
uns gekommen zu kommen um das
persönliche gespräch mit ihm zu klären
wir werden dafür sorgen dass sie die
fragen stellen können die sie und die es
eigentlich auch unzählige andere
menschen gerade haben wir übernehmen die
kosten für reise nach berlin
wir drücken ihnen natürlich ansonsten
die daumen dass das irgendwie weitergeht
sie haben es gesagt da steht immer noch
der schlamm ich weiß nicht nach so
vielen tagen ob man da überhaupt noch
kraft und stärke hat jeden morgen
irgendwie weiter zu reden wenn man noch
einmal wir wollen wir jetzt ungefähr zu
erklären wie man es stimmt wir waren
gestern im keller da waren fällen
gelagert unseren schweres regale die
kompressoren die waren alle und die
mussten wir ausschalten und ich sag
ihnen jedes teil was man da hoch ist von
der von einem fäkalien geruch wird das
begleitet also da kommt wirklich der
bürger reibt man steht da unten und wir
machen uns ja auch wir kämpfen und wir
wollen weitermachen aber dass die
politik sich dann einfach nicht kümmert
und dass man einer woche einfach
überhaupt nichts auf die reihe bekommt
und niemand weiß wo man wie jetzt hilfen
bekommt und zum beispiel dem sat 1 dann
spenden gesammelt werden von über 40
millionen euro und die frau von aktion
deutschland hilft in ihrem schlusswort
dann sagt man dem geld kaufen wir jetzt
kuscheltiere
da fühlt man sich als betroffener
einfach verarscht und man ist sauer
und man fragt sich wofür man in diesem
land eigentlich jeden monat so viel
steuern bezahlt und die hälfte seines
geldes immer wieder abgibt und wenn dann
sowas passiert einfach niemand da ist
und niemand schnell und konsequent
helfen kann es wird immer nur viel
gelabert und viel versprochen aber am
ende des tages kommt nichts bei rum
absolut gar nichts